se mi è ritornati su frey del film ho
fatto per episodio l'altro giorno vi è
piaciuto tanto anche a me perché è un po
diverso come gioco quindi continuiamo
crystal lake ski resort sua rete
sono queste situazioni dove jason è
coinvolto stata una storia in realtà
prima era lago poi era in prigione
perché l'hanno catturato adesso è
scappata dalla prigione siamo qua e
dovunque va jason ammazza gente il gioco
consiste nel fare fuori la gente
cercando di bene a far fuori la gente o
beccando li direttamente buttandoli
addosso
in questo caso le cose come che faccio
fuori casa e così fantastico tanto sto
usando cos'è
no no la prima del giorno lo mancata
porca rock
ecco poi iniziamo così vuol dire che
faremo pagare per questo sito
com'è possibile che già adesso non
capisco cosa devo fare aiuto non ti cade
addosso ma dall'altro che i capelli cat6
cagato addosso è cosa devo fare qua come
faccio a colpire la tizia michia ragazza
al diventando difficilissimi aiuto aiuto
sono stupido a me ne rendo conto da solo
non ha idea a temi e soluzioni mamma
dammi la mano che non ancora preso un
aiuto chi chi chi lava ma non ho parole
cioè se tu picchi questo tasso
c'è un tasto del menù che fa questa cosa
va bene
dovevo spaventarlo ancora ci sarei mai
arrivato
cioè è andata di purissimo il secondo
luca 1 possiamo cambiare arma che questa
mi fanno schifo a tre armi le fosse
scambiare per un'altra arma ma dai
allora coltello che bruttissimo che
questo non mi piace la trade a vedere
veramente la torcia va bene usiamola
certo puoi scambiare le armi fantastico
ma devo colpire prima con la sinistra
sicuro alla francia finché a finco e
giusto torniamo indietro forse saliamo
si era ma do un fenomeno ma cosa è una
torcia ma è una torcia non può fare un
danno così una torta vabbè farmi vedere
l'ultima chili come la fai di torcia
sempre va bene devo fare tipo così
giusto ok all e usa l'asta torcia di
nuovo usala fammi vedere che sei capace
no guarda non non avevo dubbi va
benissimo rocca un'altra arma attenzione
mi piace troppo
e bellissimo momento di sbagliarmi non
sai cosa ti può uscire da qua poi ci
mette pietro fammi vedere l'arma letale
prossima che si giocherà
hai visto che sbloccato pietro la
tavoletta del cesso chiaro fammi vedere
che arma letale riesci a farla diventare
una tavoletta del cesso perché pian
piano che vai avanti diventa sempre più
difficile quindi non è più una questione
di ammazzare tutti li devi usare i loro
corpi per arrivare alla fine di qui
adesso non ci sono arrivato perché uno
dei loro corpi lo devo usare un ostacolo
per arrivare alla fine un macello
un dato quello andato
sono andato pure io
vabbè così perfetto perfetto
fammi vedere la tavoletta zio gli era
infilata dove viene infilata scusate non
dovrebbe funzionare docenti prof
ma questo è dentro la casa
cosa volevate fare qua tutti e tre
sporca cioni si fanno ste cose ma faccio
fuori l'ultima li mortacci mia
certo mi fa ridere che lo spazio è
piccolissima non riesco a farlo farò il
tipo come è fatto dicono un po amedeo
preziosi alla famiglia delle se riesco a
far salva decentemente e figli
ok 123 vediamo come la usi stavolta zio
raga ragazzo adesso capisco perché vi
piace tanto questo gioco non avevo
capito all'inizio adesso sì che lo
capisco c'è un perché troppe di indoors
tra intrappolati dentro noi non ci sono
trappole da da da dolph quella che ci
sono anche nel gioco normale
va bene è scomparsa nel nulla allora ok
che questa era facile
ci dovrei provare a vedere se riesco a
giocare a tennis con una tavoletta del
cesso a entrare uno sbloccata come se
non fosse abbastanza tra l'altro va bene
fammi vedere cosa cifre tanto non
possiamo scendere più in basso di così è
impossibile cioè peggio della tavoletta
decesso non sono da può essere un
coltello da cucina non mi piace troppo
normale ah ok e poi
uno è sempre una brutta giornata quando
ti arriva una tavoletta del cesso in
testa lo capisco
l'ultimo non ho idea di come con come
aspetta fermo come come come dove come è
possibile spiega mi mamma aiutami
torniamo solo per lo spavento al tipo di
tipo non muore muore adesso la tipa si
caga addosso la faccio correre qua
faccio giro rischio ma come cosa è morta
è svenuta nel nulla va bene capisco bene
quanto stiamo 11 di tre pensioni la
pulizia pure pure la pula maledizione no
questo è difficile venire un attimo se
riesco a farlo studio 101 nervoso ok
questa da di qua però che così aiuto
[Musica]
non ci arrivo maledizione alla vita
rifacciamo disastro fatto incredibile
perfetto no ma perché sono scemo nella
vita morta a voi cosa succede se lo
manco quello finale non ho mai capita
nomi di da meno pubblici forse o non ha
completato il livello al massimo costa
facendo quel polizia se sei fatta così
comunque no io dovrei fare un professore
che sarei morire subito a no aspetta
ti faccio che faccio non si fa sta parte
sei un bel casino come uccido quello
senza peccare la trappola non riesco ad
arrivarci con ragionamento
ora questo vuol dire tutto se io ragiono
12 è la trappola via e fin qua
[Musica]
ok 123 ecco casino
ragazzi se vi mancano i coltelli per
affettare le cipolle prendete la
tavoletta concesso che va da dio 13esimo
livello e questo sarà difficile avere
uno
credo che più spavento meglio mi metto
la donna che bordella devo togliere
tutte le trappole in mezzo di scemi
[Musica]
ok così così ora cava che non vogliono
anche fare questa cosa così bene
e l'ultimo dove a lei è l'ultimo ok ma è
brutto ma che brutta roma ho visto
winter kills laviamo finite tutte
ragazze so passiamo alla città manhattan
adattano al nuovo problema ioni e zombie
adesso zombie jason non perché
normalmente jason è un umano tutti e
vertigo
[Musica]
quindi dopo il ghiacciaio passiamo a
manhattan non so bene perché ma è una
nave a caso completamente a casa sono
dei poliziotti già subito partiamo
malissimo
ecco c'è il telefono che distrae la
gente va bene
a proprio distrae tutti sulla n ciao zio
che una chiave inglese e una forchetta
come arma ma cos'è questa è una perché
devo cambiare urgentemente arma però
facciamo dopo tanto tempo di sì l'oscar
ma nuova allora ecco no machete ma
scelta un'arma vera regalarmi finte
dovete darmi degli ato non a norma cette
cambia cambiamo subito e la torcia dai
trader
ma perfetto una caffettiera eccola qui
la zia perfetto famiglia come funziona
[Musica]
guarda già non ho parole ma cos'è ea
prima affilatissima con la caffettiera
capisco subito chi è questo va bene non
importa via
sto facendo ma cos'è ma non è neanche
usata la caffettiera avere ragazzi però
oggi secondo me abbiamo visto veramente
tanto a kakà ma badantato facendo
veramente tanto sto gioco è un po strano
però è figo proprio gli sia piaciuto
ragazzi con quell'episodio come se ci
riusciremo a te mi piace anche la lista
che mi vedo bene iniziare senato e si
ritiene non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]